our india correspondent elizabeth
puranam reports
[Applause]
desperate parents carry their children
to this hospital in firozabad in uttar
pradesh state for the past two weeks it
has been inundated with children
suffering from high temperatures and
other symptoms of dengue fever
muhammad azim's six-month-old daughter
anya has tested positive for the
mosquito-borne virus he says his
three-year-old nephew arthur has also
been unwell
she's had a fever for several days and
has been taking medicines when her
condition didn't improve i brought her
here but it took more than three hours
for them to look at her it is difficult
for a common man to have access to
doctors here
most of those who have died from dengue
fever in the past two weeks are children
definitely patients are coming here
most are in the pediatric age group
and
all are presenting maximum patients are
presenting with fever diarrhea dysentery
abdominal pain
cases of the virus usually rise during
the monsoon season in tropical climates
but health officials say the outbreak is
particularly bad this year
[Music]
municipal workers are spraying chemicals
to kill mosquitoes in the cinema nugget
neighborhood
pushpendra lost his six-year-old son
krishna to the dengue virus
there are a lot of children who are sick
in our neighborhood some have dengue
some are fever half of the children from
here are in hospital
just recently a child right opposite our
house was admitted two children who live
their own house have died
dengue is transmitted by mosquitoes
which breed in and around stagnant water
in many parts of philosophized people
live next to open drains and in more
than one third of homes in indian cities
wastewater is released from the house
through an open drainage system
health experts say the drains are a
breeding ground for diseases but that
spraying isn't a long-term solution they
say the government needs to do more
feruzabad's chief medical officer told
al jazeera the worst of the outbreak is
over but that wasn't the picture at the
city's biggest children's hospital
elizabeth puranam al-jazeera therozabad
uttar pradesh